two
we are here with another
banger alert
banger alert
i've just peed in my basement the
quartering making an appearing in the
introduction today haven't heard from
him in a while
welcome everybody
off the rails
fantastic episode sponsored by curology
kraken mint mobile policy genius let's
go thank you sponsors we love you so
much quick shout out to teddy fresh ela
kleiners unites
um this shirt i'm wearing is restock the
tattoo tee that everyone seemed to love
is back in stock on the website here
also the hooded
work it work it
also the hooded corduroy shirt is back
the classic is back beautiful wow what a
garment huh gorgeous head on over to
teddyfresh.com uh there's some restocks
lots of classics everything is looking
good my dudes these socks just dropped
too by the way
teddy bear socks i mean come on who
wouldn't want this
work it work it work it work it
that's it teddyfresh.com thank you thank
you peace and love
ryan kavanagh
doing this
yeah just dropped a fat bill on the
lawsuit boy
yeah i bet
there's uh
some updates coming fairly soon to that
right
this week there's some filings
and then
we have oral arguments
sometime this month oh yeah there's a
lot happening this month hey hey
um exciting stuff
daddy's spending a lot of money on this
stupid gag
[Music]
six figures for sure boy
lovely
hey hey hey yeah well hopefully ryan
will be footing the bill for everything
we'll see
i've never actually sued for attorney's
fees because with matt haas where like
he's broke it's pointless right but
kavkav
has a few coins in his bank apparently
we'll see
yeah so i'm not even sure i think with
the attorney's fees also it's not like
you don't necessarily get all of it
you'll get like a portion of it
is that crap
should we get all of it i don't know
like it could be 50 it could be i guess
what's weird about attorney's fees is
it's totally at the discretion of the
judge
they say you know it's it's interesting
thing so anyway uh in honor of ryan
kavanagh costing me six figures here
i did want to read one trailer review as
i think it's important we don't forget
that you know
being members of uh social media it is
our duty to give you know to inform the
public
uh good or bad on apps to give them
reviews
so this one was called
because of trailer i was nailed to a
wooden tee so a crucifixion perhaps oh
my god
yeah the developers responded to this
one
did they know yeah
downloading this app was something i was
looking forward to
i started it and quickly found many of
the features to be upside down
oh so noah beck also had that what did
he call it referred to as flipped right
he mentioned that i didn't get it so
then i asked some buddies of mine about
it and they freaked i tried to tell them
the realities but they didn't listen
eventually it worked though and when i
tried to tell them it's nothing to worry
about they got even more enraged
in the middle of the night they dragged
me outside onto this tea like structure
made of wood
i was terrified i had to drag the wooden
tee to a hill near my home while they
forced me to listen to da baby and
nickelback on repeat i was distraught as
i dragged the t they kept asking me to
stand up even though i was already
dragging the t in standy when i finally
made it to the hill they played clips of
harvey weinstein on a vr headset i was
so scared although i did notice he
looked like the owner of triller ryan
kavanagh
they later nailed me by feet and hands
to this big wooden tee i was in pain but
what hurt more was the constant vr
of uh
ryan cat i mean harvey weinstein and
nickelback the baby this is my trailer
experience using the app nice color way
though
and then the developers responded they
say hi we appreciate you reaching out
if you are having issues with the app
please let us know at support
triller.com thank you so
well at least they're responsive to the
uh complaints of their of their music
flipped i wonder if they can do anything
about his friends crucifying him
because that seemed to be the main
that was the main thrust of the review
really sure yeah sure was oh jesus yeah
so if you guys want to leave your
reviews of triller
you know give it a fair give it a try
give it a fair shake
and then leave your uh review of triller
um this is ryan cavanaugh by the way the
ceo anyway
uh
we've got a great show so squid games
obviously uh
all the talk about town
so we have planned our very own squid
games h3 podcast
we are going to be executing everybody
but one of us
sorry
yes
i haven't seen the show so
you mean metaphorically
no
no no no
many of us will die today
are you playing yes i am of course i am
okay
fair enough
yeah
um
but we've we've been hard at work
putting together our own squid game so
we're very excited we were going to
shoot each other with paintballs but we
did a trial run with ian ian you want to
show your back
i i sent it in the uh discord oh we got
the image okay i need a machine gun yeah
so
dan was talking a big game the other day
about how it hits so soft and it's not a
big deal and so we're like okay well
there's ian's back
and this is right after being shot with
it and so everyone was like that's a
little intense
yes
how are you feeling does it hurt still
no i mean it went away okay that's good
but the welter lives on the welt will
live on yeah so i think we're going to
take some assault gun to the dome
dome shot right in the eye
ian i wish you the best
i'll say if that is
yeah but it'll be fun
um
yeah the squid game thing is pretty
phenomenal like the act has everyone
here seen the show though for real i
haven't oh you never watched it
did everyone else see it yeah yeah
you guys like it yeah it was really good
i've all been raving i was a big
proponent of it early on
you know i just liked it before it was
cool that's right which was what like
one minute
[ __ ] dude whatever you want to call it
i'm just that cool i actually heard
about it from the first time from love
so he's really the og
hipster that's right that's right he was
the one that told us about it starting
[ __ ] well i watched i watched it as soon
as i saw on the homepage not knowing
anything about it and i thought we me
and elo both watched it we thought it
was great
i didn't expect the full-on phenomenon
though it's become the most popular show
in netflix history
and the actors are all becoming like
mega freaking famous for example
the actress one of the the actresses
who's a korean model
went from
400 000 before the the show to 14
million in the course of like seven days
which is pretty
i mean
this is her you guys probably all
recognize her if you've been in the show
she's at 15.3 million now
yeah um
yes she's already doing a louis vuitton
thing like they scooped her ass up dude
you know
five million likes in seven hours
and louis vuitton by the way they
usually get like 20 000 likes you know
on their post
they dropped this look at this almost a
million likes whatever they spent it was
worth it by
damn
they made her the ambassador they're
like girl you're on fire we're gonna
make you the ambassador
of fashion watches and jewelry damn
hey that was me
so there you go the netflix effect
and um
let me show you guys
the from from the social blade
because this is this is super
interesting here she is before the movie
or before the show dropped she was
getting 200
400 0 the day before
right
when did when was the show released
it was released on the 17th i believe
okay so here's here it comes out
the next day 20
250
a million you know here on up up on the
30th
2 million and now she's getting like a
million a day easy
pretty amazing eh yeah i was gonna say
slime whistle up
yeah and now she's the most followed uh
korean
model slash actress the most followed
korean woman i think on instagram
so there you have it
she beat out all those k-pop stars
because that's pretty impressive wait
that can't be true can it i mean
it says the most followed uh south
korean actors wait those black pink
girls have to be super popular that's
kind of what i was thinking of somebody
like somebody like that can someone fact
check that out everybody says what's the
one that stan stan luna yeah someone
fact check that because that would be
amazing if she
let's see luna
oh
well
the group has only two million followers
on instagram what
i thought i figured they would have so
much i don't know if that's the biggest
though um black pink is really big
instagram
let's see what blackpink's got going i
think that's 42 million okay there you
go 42 million there there you go but
that's that's a band my my speaker's
coming in too hot here guys if you could
turn it down a little bit thank you
yeah but what about the individuals uh
in the band does do they not have more
than her
14 million i do not know the names of
the individuals in the band sure but
somebody back there probably would be
able to figure that out thank you lisa
blackpink
maybe
no that's a fan account
well anyway someone uh researched that
just kind of out of curiosity
but one thing this video needs
k-pop you zach
yeah but it's pretty interesting the
whole korean
the korean uh cultural phenomenon
happening
there is just like i mean k-pop kind of
start well i don't know if it started
but like oh yeah she has 62 million yeah
this is one of the black print members
yeah so that's what i thought so anyway
um
shout out
you know but all the cast of the squid
games are like totally blowing up on
social media
and uh
god bless
love that
i'm only waiting for that one guy to get
finally get his recognition the uh the
guy who's trying trying to turn his race
into south korean
what's his name ali yeah ali i'm just
waiting for ollie to finally get
recognized
as the first trans-racial person
ali south korean
london holly london you do london you
got to change that name bro
how about ollie's soul
identical bro
yeah
all right so that's what we have coming
up here uh it's going to be fun ela's
going to be joining us for that as well
meanwhile
new wendy william memes generating
let's see
look i don't know what's going on i
don't know you're gonna oh you're gonna
wait this is new
[Applause]
this is new
it is new no [ __ ] way
wait what it sounded like a burp fart
this is a new burp fart it's a different
one yeah what no way yeah look i don't
know what's going on i don't know you're
gonna oh you're gonna
how can you burp fart twice on the same
show
are you sure this isn't the same one
i i do you want me to a b it okay so
it's not a new clip
but it is a different fart burp
so this is a newly discovered wendy
williams fart burp now here is the the
one that we have been using as a sound
bite it's a matter of time she's not
lonely
i apologize why are her why is her
[ __ ] and mouth like
synced up in such a way where when she
barbs she farts i mean it's so
fascinating
so here's the other one which happens in
the same style look i don't know what's
going on i don't know you're gonna oh
you're gonna
[Music]
i love the damn
i got me again
that sphincter mouth connection they're
uh
they're synced up man the crazy thing is
the same pitch like they're identical
yeah you got to play them back to back
for me zach i want to do a total sound
comparison
but is she okay my question now is she
farting or is it some kind of like burp
thing because like why would she fire
every time what's going on i don't know
you're gonna oh you're gonna
she goes maybe she goes
like she catches herself
yeah know what's going on i don't know
you're going to oh you're going to ha
whoop she's just going whoop
you think it's i want to i want it to be
a fart i'm leaning towards fart and i'm
usually the skeptic but i really i want
it to be a fire what's going on i don't
know you're gonna oh you're gonna ha
at least she's going
that sounds like a fart there's too much
there's too much uh
i don't know what's going on i don't
know you're gonna you're gonna hop
look there's even like a there's like a
slight like
well switch when the fart happens right
and she is a notorious farter i mean
we've caught her ripping ass before yeah
she has uh she she has some condition
right yeah
motion maybe that's not as funny dan
well but just i mean that is why she
toots look at looking at the wave file
of it i've seen a lot of fartwell oh
here we go zach is in the laboratory
it's it looks like a fart i'm zach
you're telling me you can tell it
between a fart and a whoop yes
yes i can really
it's funny i'm reading an article and it
says that every time she says something
messed up that it's karma like she was
making from joaquin phoenix's cleft lip
all right right yeah and then right
after that's when she did this really
how did this go under the radar because
we are like connoisseurs
okay well here i'm gonna slow it down so
this is so shout out to joaquin phoenix
this one is uh god put that fart in her
ass for you but what's going on
i don't know
how
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
interesting
it sounds like she's going oop yeah i
don't know
you see that kind of changes things for
me do you see it she goes
yeah you can see her mouth move right
oop here let's let's here let's
let's slow it let's speed it up a little
bit because it's very slow right and
let's see if that gives us a new like a
cleaner perspective maybe zach do you
have some csi music please
[Music]
she's definitely saying oop
i hate to say it because i want to
believe she's furry i was i was leaning
fart but but the slo-mo has brought me
around but now we have to go back
and examine the first one was it
is this one a fire or is it also an oop
oh it's a matter of time she's not
lonely
because
she's covering her mouth at the moment
of christ
but
what's interesting this one seems more
clear-cut to me this one seems more like
a fart yeah but
no you're going you just sped it up oh
[ __ ]
but but it's the same exact sound to dan
i agree it's really similar but not
lonely
that one sounds like a that's far more
horn-like yeah that one's a fart
i'm not going to defend that one
that's a [ __ ] that's a
that's a tune right there
okay so at least we still have one burp
fart because i i would be devastated if
we lost both of them
that one is so clean bro
yeah so
but zach if you're able to play them
side by side i'd like to analyze them if
possible
you want the first one first or you want
from the article it says the gas was
released in quick succession a guttural
eruption ricocheted by a butthole
speaker
released so fast it almost gave viewers
whiplash so she has a speaker on her
butthole that explains why we could hurt
it that would definitely spark
yeah fart mic
you said this is from an article what
article was
from uh this one's from vice and it's
talking about how after she was making
fun of kim and kanye's divorce
she erupted she erupted god there is a
car there's an ass karma god
the god of farts
go ahead zach you got it for me yep so
here is the original one the first one
okay
okay
and here is
okay now play them just go back and
forth for me
again
[Laughter]
i get they sound the same go ahead
please sound the same
i sort of disagree i feel like the one
that we think is a fart is far more of a
of a horn-like quality to it it sounds
like look at the waveform that's all i'm
saying
okay how do we look at the waveform zac
i've seen enough fart
recordings in my life that i don't think
that holds up in court dude
it's solid evidence
not it's not or the gas isn't solid so
not as solid maybe it was solid we
didn't get the look in our
underwear this is the first time for
this is far from the first time the
brash talk show has just let a ripe one
loose on air
february 2020
or january 2020 she was once again
delivered her hot topic segment and let
me tell you it wasn't the only hot topic
that came out of her body
this is the first time for me in uh and
wendy williams fart mike
the hot topic segment while perched in a
leaning position on her rose-colored
velvet chair one butt cheek up off the
seat as she looked directly at the
camera we heard a loud cartoonish like
fart sound
who wrote this article props the the
pros
is so elegant and so well the incident
was later coined fart gate yeah that's
fantastic alex
zaragoza
shout out to the gozard
yeah do you have the loud cartoonish
like fart sound that you could throw in
the mix sack
so let's let's do a full analysis of her
farts
and i'd like to just submit for the for
the jury
if we could please a full profile
to get to the bottom of this no pun
intended which order would you like
any order
play the fart the cartoon fart
one second
that is not it
what cartoon part are you friends wendy
williams oh
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i don't recall that sound but
maybe maybe it was just a reminder wendy
has said i have never farted once on
this show that's a [ __ ] lie she said
as a matter of fact i barely fart lying
rat she farts readily how dare you lie
to your audience
so here's the one that uh started it all
there's no [ __ ] way here is the
not the newest one
and then here is the newest the new
discovered one
that middle one is not a fart
the middle one is the one yeah where kim
and kanye are in the background right i
thought that one was
pretty convincing but just play the
first one for me dan
i mean zach
no the the real fart
the fart gate
[Music]
people won't won't believe us that that
is a straight up
captured from her
unedited unedited unpitched yeah that's
something man well
wendy whatever it is girl i hope you're
uh
getting on top of that maybe less i
don't know
whatever you're eating change your diet
i guess i don't know what to tell you
the slim jams dude with the oh the
whiter the burnt slim jibs will
definitely make you [ __ ] your pants
she also mentioned in 2017 once on the
show that i had beans for breakfast
beans for breakfast no wonder you're
coming out there
[ __ ]
guns blazing
blasting nut broke she's probably
blasting nugs into her thong
like it can't even contain that [ __ ]
probably just slices it in half like
deli meat
just sayin
surprised
what this woman's like she's eating slim
jims and beans for breakfast i mean no
wonder
yeah i mean she claims that she barely
farts but
it says people with graves disease tend
to have frequent loose stools or
diarrhea so
i mean do the math that's evidence right
there do the math
i don't know do the math
let's talk less about her actual illness
because that makes me feel bad oh
let's not talk about just trying to
understand you know i'm just kidding i'm
kidding what is graves
it's a hyperactive thyroid it says
yeah your immune system is that why her
uh her eyes are kind of buggy too
because i know that's a thyroid thing
yes i think so yeah that is yeah all
right well we wish you well wendy
obviously just maybe list some gems and
beans i don't know that can't help i
mean not a doctor but
i can't imagine that that's on the
recommended
maybe just after the show
right
i don't know i feel like that style of
gas you can't really hold you know
that's what i'm saying if you okay thank
you
[Laughter]
uh
oh this is a really interesting
conversation i wanted to possibly bring
up uh sam and olivia we're gonna need
you for this
this recently came to my attention okay
and here's a here is a
message from our subreddit with peace
and love
attention men
and some women
of the h3 subreddit stop referring to
women as females
now i had never i first i don't know
what for a reason i i guess i'm guilty
of saying females up until recently i
stopped i started saying women
um
because
uh
i guess i was i kept saying females over
at teddy fresh in chats and stuff and
eli was like you have to stop saying
that and i was like what
so
there is a
movement to
request to men and all people to stop
saying female
do you have thoughts on this sam
um
i definitely i i understand where uh
people are coming from i don't think i
have a
huge huge opinion on it but i do think
that it is a little bit
i guess disrespectful in a way i mean i
would prefer to
be called
i don't know woman i don't know so
saying like i guess you females or
something like that is just kind of like
i don't know i i don't know it's kind of
disrespectful i guess i used to use it
as like uh when i was referring to our
women's line i would say uh female
clothing
but so is what i guess what's
disrespectful i guess i didn't
understand there's some really good
explanations here in the
in the thread which i hadn't heard about
but they're saying it radiates in cell
energy and i had never
consciously been aware
of the difference does this come a
surprise to the guys in the crew yeah i
actually
the first time i heard about this was
from ila i think we were talking about
it but uh
yeah i mean i guess if it's an
individual i i understand that makes
sense what sam was just saying you're
referring to someone individually but
the way we were discussing it like you
said was referring to a
female clothing line or female
drop i believe
which i i mean
well so the rationale here
which i thought was good
here let me find it was that
i've never heard a guy refer to a group
of men as males
just makes you wonder why it's cringey
i'm not offended i'm just telling you
off the bat you most likely do not hold
men and women in the same regard
you can be mad at opie but i guarantee
you i heard a heard a man say female in
this context i would 100 not smash well
that that's compel that's important
that's reason enough the word this was a
good one the word female can be used to
describe a female dog a female cat
female frogs etc but if you're referring
to a female woman there's already a word
for that it's a woman female human it
says a female human right yeah so so the
woman
i guess they saying the female can be
gendered to anything
the woman is a woman you don't hear not
gendered but like species yeah it's it's
a it's a human
right a female child is a girl
the dislike for the word isn't in
regards to scientific or when used as an
adjective adjective example she is a
female rapper so wait that is okay
opposed to
that female
which is using the word in a negative
connotation yeah so you so they're
saying so we can use female she's a
female rapper that's okay
yeah because i've been confused about
that because i've been trying to stop
saying female but in some context it's
weird to be like she's a woman rapper
that sounds weird it does seem more
stilted when you say it yeah i think
it's a similar argument where uh
comedians who are women don't want to be
called female comedians they just want
to be called comedians well yeah there's
that okay which that's fair okay fair
enough it's the same thing she's a
rapper she's a wrap she's a rapper you
don't need to include the yeah i mean i
feel like i kind of get one man it's it
it does feel like uh he's a man he's a
man rapper no one would say that right
yeah exactly it's like
if you just say rap i guess it's just
implying that if you say rapper you
assume well if you say she's a rapper
all the information you need is there
right that's true
typically the word female is used in an
aggressive manner and has a tendency to
replace the word [ __ ]
in like in cell spaces i mean that part
of it i definitely have seen yeah i've
definitely seen
like 4chan type memes and that kind of
she's a female yeah
where they're talking despair like they
use female a lot when they're talking
about how
females only care about getting their
money and
you know that kind of [ __ ] some
people use the word female to dehumanize
women particularly patriarchy and toxic
masculinity use the word female in a
negative tone women can also use the
word in a negative manner as well
especially when using it as a curse
insult
these [ __ ] females interesting i mean
this is all good this is all good
information because i was kind of uh
listen when i learned about this i was
kind of uh
surprised by it all but i immediately
started saying women obviously because i
want to be respectful but i guess it's
good to know because apparently there's
other people
uh still
out there
saying female
yeah i appreciate the explanation uh
especially in regards to like oh well
you know there's females of all species
but a human
female is called a woman because
i've always felt like it seems weird and
stilted to use to phrase it that way as
well but i don't know if i would have
been able to articulate why yeah that
was a good
odd to say like oh these females over
here what feels wrong a female dog would
be fine woman dog right woman dog
doesn't make sense
uh is olivia here oh she's no she's at
the doctor's appointment right now oh
okay
well there you have it guys hope that
was helpful zack do you have anything to
add
uh i mean this is uh i appreciate this
information and um
yeah i uh does this come as a surprise
to you a little bit yeah but um i
definitely will curve my language
accordingly curb it up lock it up bro
yeah um
yeah i'm i mean i find it interesting
and um
yeah i will definitely like i said i
just thought myself i appreciate that
they articulated exactly why because
because i
instinctively felt like that was awkward
phrasing to to use female but i wouldn't
have really been able to put a finger on
why that feels so awkward but i think
that's a good point about female well
being a more broad thing than the truth
is we do have a lot of women in our
audience so i want to be obviously
respectful as possible and welcoming to
them
this person said i completely agree i
know it's well intentioned but there was
a post on the sub a couple of days ago
that referred to women as menstruators
now that i understand is derogatory
that one makes sense to me that's pretty
cut and dry i'm all for being inclusive
but to narrow down people to a bodily
function and being labeled that is
insulting and gross i'm on your side
there you go see that guy gets it he
sent using the correct i'm gonna try and
find the language
guys this is important apparently
calling women females gives huge in-cell
vibes so guys out there definitely this
is good information
um
lock it up
like if you're saying uh
if you're asking and i'm not saying one
way or another i'm just curious if
you're asking like
who's your favorite
female athlete that's not appropriate
what if you who's your favorite female
athlete right because yeah i've stumbled
and i go who's your favorite
woman athlete that doesn't sound right
right does it well if you're referring
to a man you say what's your favorite
you wouldn't you wouldn't you just say
who's your favorite athlete
right well yeah i mean that that's one
element of the argument but i'd say
even separate from that like you said
the phrasing
women athlete i mean that one doesn't
is your favorite woman athlete i guess
you could say that or just athlete
that's a woman who's your favorite
athlete that's a woman yeah i guess
that's a less awkward way to phrase it
is it less awkward
i don't know who is your favorite artist
that is a woman who's your favorite
woman well i guess the argument could be
that who's your fa but
so wait wait wait what are the because
they they often have women categories
for stuff like awards so how do they
phrase it like it during an award show
they say see at the grammys the top
women actress or they would say actress
uh best actress or
uh because that's another thing
apparently
women now are act because it used to be
actress rate and now it's actor
so how would they say
right actor well that's yeah and i guess
that could be applied to asking a
question like who's your favorite female
athlete then it should just be who's
your favorite athlete maybe but
but then again we have being specific
you're asking right
because we have separate leagues as well
so wnba mba so
yeah i don't know well there aren't
they're categories in the grammys like
female not anymore i actually just
looked it up in in 2012 they got rid of
that they just it's it's uh unisex now
like best or best pop solo performance
as men and women in it and what it used
to be female people yeah it was it was a
best female pop vocal performance so
they did use the female yeah but again
this is almost a decade ago that they
got rid of that yeah
do you have any insight sam for us
um
i feel like just saying female just kind
of boils people down to their sex and
another
another point that i saw was that not
all women are female
um
so i guess that's just something else to
keep in mind all women
not all people that identify as women
are
uh like biological biologically female
right
okay so the female is more of a
biological
thing right right woman is a gender
thing right interesting okay i'm trying
to find the menstruators posts on the
skin
that's [ __ ] up but i don't know maybe
i'm spelling it wrong
people who menstruate is that okay sam
or we like that or no um i've i've heard
that
be used i mean i i
would not prefer that for myself but you
can call me a person who jizzes if you
would please
i'd prefer to be known as a
it's very it's very inclusive yeah thank
you you're a come straighter would be
the expression
a come straighter yeah
he's making a play on the menstruator
though oh come straight
straight yeah that's stupid
all right well this has been everywhere
this has been a public service
announcement with peace and love i think
it's an interesting thing too no more
female thank you thank you this is a
serious message to everybody watching my
update right now peace and love
after the 6th of october no more female
thank you thank you and no menstruating
persons
either if you're going to call women
female you're going to get tossed right
i'm warning you with peace and love
we have too much to do
so
thank you thank you
we love our women
we respect our women
and we thank you for being here
all right on that note uh
love
a woman
the man speaks truth
he speaks in the truth
all right we gotta go to break well i
for one i'm glad to learn that because i
don't want to be giving off bad vibes
you know absolutely yeah yeah i've i've
heard you say it a number of times and
female you're calling me out
you know that you have that's the whole
point i cut it out i stopped saying it
i'm saying yes i'm saying in the past oh
so now all of a sudden
you've had silently been suffering me
saying female
and you're so woke dan go ahead
listen i'm sure i've i'm sure i've said
it at some point in another two
i was just going to say yes
you're okay dan
thank you joe never mind let's go to
break how about that
we're way over all right we'll go to
break and when we come back uh
it's squid games
time to take a short break
thank you rudy
thank you to curology i love this
service i use it myself
um guys it's time to take care of our
skin
it's important damn it and i know it's a
pain in the ass i've i've avoided it my
whole life but curology makes it easy
and they hook you up with licensed
dermatology
services
and how it works is you send them a
photo of your skin you answer a few
questions
and they hook you up with a licensed
dermatology provider
to formulate
a simple little cream that you apply to
your face to help with whatever problem
you're having it may be
that you're having
there's all kinds of different things
people have there's fine lines there's
dark spots there's occasional breakouts
clogged pores they're gonna see and
they're gonna formulate it for you now
they sent me three products one's a
gentle face wash which is great because
i hate when my skin dries out the one is
the dermatology
uh prescribed
cream
and then the moisturizer and that's the
routine it's easy
and it really
i have felt the difference to be quite
honest with you guys and uh what can i
say i'm a fan
here's how it works curology customizes
a prescription formula with three active
ingredients pick for you to help tackle
your skin care needs
uh you know
fine lines dark spots occasional
breakouts clogged pores you start by
answering questions online about your
skin and it's if it's a good fit
curology will match you with a licensed
dermatology provider who will get to
know your skin subject to consultation
you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your door
um guys you can start your curology
journey just like me with a free 30-day
trial at curology.com
h3
if prescribed you're gonna pay just five
dollars for shipping and handling that's
c u r o l o g y dot com slash h3 to
unlock your free
30-day trial thank you thank you
curology
release the kraken
the crapton crypto currencies exchange
that is in the kraken app hey guys if
you're interested investing in
cryptocurrencies but aren't sure where
to get started please check out the
kraken app
with kraken you can buy and sell over 50
of the most popular cryptos like bitcoin
dogecoin and ethereum on the go 24 7.
it's super easy to get started just
download the app create your account and
you're going to be investing in minutes
one of the coolest things about buying
crypto through kraken is that you don't
need a lot of money to try it out
bitcoin might be trading at forty
thousand 000
but you can get in the door with as
little as 10 bucks buy a little bit of
of bitcoin
see how you like it get your feet wet
learn the game
find out for yourself why kraken has
been one of the highest rated places to
buy crypto for the last 10 years visit
kraken.com atrial or more or search for
kraken in the app store and uh guys a
friend of the show we love kraken so if
you're interested
in crypto please consider going to
kraken.com
h3 thank you thank you
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers if we've learned anything it's
that there's always a catch but when i
first heard that mint mobile offers
premium wireless services that start at
just 15 bucks a month i thought well
what is the catch but after speaking
with them using their service it all
made sense there is not a catch mint
mobile secret sauce is that the first
company to sell wireless services online
only by cutting out retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs to get
passed down to you in the form of
mysterious fees instead meant
passes those savings directly onto you
now listen
you might think that there's a
difference in uh and a service but dan
can tell you
it's it's the same [ __ ] it works just as
good it really does
[Music]
you know it's just about saving money
you're gonna be spending what 15 bucks a
month you're gonna be getting the same
service you're currently using it's just
as good in fact they use the same
network
um
yeah how's your experience been with
meant dan
yeah like i've said before uh i
switched over from one of the big boys
you you know who they are um and
honestly
couldn't tell you
any difference other than it's about a
quarter of the price it's 20 21 guys
it's all the same [ __ ] the tech is there
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month and all plans come
with unlimited talk and tax plus high
speed data delivered on the nation's
largest 5g network exactly
use your phone use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan and keep the same
number along with all your existing
contacts and if you're not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee so switch
over to mint mobile and get premium
wireless services starting at just 15
bucks a month they get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped straight to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
h3 that's mint
mobile.com
h3 cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month admit mobile.com h3 thank you
thank you thank you to the geniuses at
policy genius what's scarier than
getting a box of raisins while
trick-or-treating that is scary
terrifying but it's paying too much for
home and auto insurance you know but
policy genius is going to help you avoid
that ever happening to you policy genius
makes it easy to compare home and auto
insurance all in one place they can help
you find
home and auto coverage similar to what
you have now but at a much lower price
they've saved customers on average 1 250
per year over what they were previously
paying for home and auto insurance
they've saved new customers on average
435 dollars per year on auto insurance
and they've saved the same new customers
350 per year on home assurance alone
their team handles all the paperwork to
set up your new policy and to switch
over to the new ones getting started is
super easy first head to
policygenius.com
h3 podcast and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property then policy genius takes it
from there they'll compare rates from
the top insurers
from progressive to allstate to find you
the lowest quotes
uh the policy genius team can look for
ways to save you more including bundling
your home and auto policies
and if they are able to find a better
rate than what you're paying now they'll
switch you over all for free their
top-notch service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across trustpilot and google head to
policygenius.com h3 podcast to get
started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right thank you
thank you
welcome back everybody um olivia's here
and uh i wanted to get your take on the
female woman i know we kind of closed
the book on it but i'm just curious to
get your take since you just arrived um
i mean if someone says that i won't
immediately write them off and be like
oh they're a horrible person but
i will roll my eyes really yeah
i mean if it's a general statement and
someone is like females always do this
it feels like
like
it feels like i'm a statistic or like a
data point good to know
and shannon you have uh you also share
that uh
yeah for me at least um it all depends
on like the context like sometimes if i
hear it just generally i'm like okay but
if someone's like these females at least
for me because female is like used as a
scientific term and woman is more
referring to them as like human beings
so like i said it depends on context
like if someone's saying it kind of
aggressively i'm like
what's going on there um but if it's
used generally uh i don't see why not
but sometimes like as women we're just
like when it's said to us we're like oh
where's that coming from um so yeah
that's just my take on it okay well this
is all very good to know so once again
peace and love no more females thank you
thank you
well
not no more females but no more females
yes they they kind of come together as
women right okay i see i'm not saying
kill females right
no more
i have relationships with women
so um
yo we looked at this guy previously and
uh he does some like
self-defense courses
we watched him in his warehouse
you guys remember this video anyway he
dropped the new child protection
technique
nice which is fire
uh this guy self-defense from a child
kidnapping
all right so the way that worked
when the man grabbed yo this you're
losing your kids bruh you're losing your
kids
the way he just phases into the frame
with the [ __ ] literally nothing happened
you're losing your kid lady you're
losing your kid
nothing i mean all she did was grab his
hand
back up i mean
i think the situation's more serious
than that i'm going to war somebody
grabs my kid like that
ain't no backups here that's literally
the self-defense from king of the hill
with bobby i didn't see that you don't
know what i'm talking about or
he's instructed to just like yell loudly
i don't know you
that's my purse i don't know you
right yeah pretty much
all right so the way that worked
when the man grabbed the child's arm
the mother
pushed here on the thumb
causing the thumb to let go oh my god
this would help if someone tries to grab
you oh he's got no sleeves break the
hold so you can get okay wait i want to
test this theory because i know when
somebody latches on to something it's
very hard to get their hand off but
according to him
push the thumb
let's do a theory test here
um do we have any children do we have
any small children
that i can latch onto
cam's pretty small
camp free from an aggressor that tries
to abduct your child self-defense from a
child kidnapping
all right so we need someone to perform
the thumb unlock
cam we've got cam and a b we're gonna do
a demonstration here guys please
now this is important you this could
save your child's life someday
okay so who wants to be the grav step
behind ethan sit behind me please
gentlemen
okay thank you now abe you want to grab
cam's uh arm and hold on tight hold on
as hard as you can like you're about to
kidnap this kid you got plans for this
good boy that is so true all right so
now you don't know
so now he's saying just push the thumb
away right okay so we're pushing the
thumb not having much progress
not having just push you're pulling
you're pulling the phone okay you gotta
push so wait you loosen your thumb
wait wait hold on hold on tight
okay you all right ken
break your arm the camera is like safe
all right so i'm pushing the thumb away
i'm pushing yeah okay but i think the k
is gone by coming
driving you home
sister
hey back up back up
back up okay he's free
wow
what do you think baby wow i'm sold what
do you think about that i was really
afraid of twisting his arm too much
so you you aren't giving your full force
okay one more time i was just playing
okay okay all right get that music now
you want this kid
you got big plans for this kid now baby
you're you're a priest in in france yeah
exactly
you got you got all right here we go you
got big plans for this kid
you got big plans now baby and i'm here
to stop you i'm here to stop you okay
i mean
awesome situation neutralized
sisters
here just real quick so you know what i
was talking about
that's my purse i don't know you
that's more effective that's way more
effective than what he's teaching yeah
it worked
oh does that mean i learned that in
self-defense
the kick and the balls move no the wrist
movement oh the wrist move okay you
learned that i did i just attacked the
thumb yeah it's pretty
dumb but i learned other things that are
pretty helpful i think do you want to
teach us
um if you are held in a chokehold put
all of your weight down and then they
won't be able to support you
you guys want to test that one exactly
come choke me
choke me daddy
they also when when you attack they make
you say like verbal commands so if i'm
taking my heel and like hitting it into
the guy's face they make you say like
eyes eyes and it's it's a it's a real
performance wait say what like if i go
for his eyes you want to scream eyes i
scream that's just the way that they
teach you
guys [ __ ] yeah
they're like elbow elbow eyes you scream
what you're doing i mean for the like
final presentation yeah i did for my
graduation oh wow
olivia's trained
[Music]
don't you dare you just drop down if
you're being choked you said that that
makes sense but then you're on the
ground that's probably
well obviously you don't get choked but
okay good let's see
so well you're in a chair so obviously
stand up
so i just drop my weight a little bit
and just choke him as hard as you can
zach put your hands around and then drop
your weight okay go ahead behind
like strangle him straight choke his ass
he has like [ __ ] giant hands okay and
i dropped my weight yeah just like pull
your feet
just go limp wait shouldn't it shouldn't
exactly be choking from the front yeah i
don't know what this is
that wait wait zach you should be
choking from the front yeah i don't
think anyone chokes from the back
i can't jerk off to this
[ __ ] yeah i mean choking from the back
you take you take your arms put them on
top of his and then drop it away
zoom out a little there you go and then
while while you're being choked amy can
you please say daddy to zach
daddy chill okay you know what now put
both of your take both of your hands
around his arm both hands zach ryan's
arm yeah around his eyes grab his arm
this one too and then drop all your
weight just like follow the ground fall
to the floor but then you're on the
floor
yeah but you're not being choked anymore
yeah but you're on the floor you're
gonna get something and then we'll deal
with the combat that we learned for
floor work right now are you a floor
combat oh we've got floor work yeah then
you bust out the
notes i don't know my self-defense uh
recommendation is just carrie mace
because all this all this silliestness
is gonna get your ass
my first week in college in detroit the
first thing they told us is mace doesn't
work
i mean they said it's not going to be
effective i mean it works but it's not
going to be effective they're like if
someone get up you won't see them come
in you want tesla well what are you
supposed to do just die
what was that would be better just to
run well court run mace i think it's all
a combination mace floor work right
nothing falling to the floor and then
trying to grapple with your assailant
the classy i know moves i was top moves
all right who wants to grapple with
olivia
can i kick a b
like can he try and defend that oh yeah
i'll sanction that
let's save that for the squid games yeah
yeah just come on
you know
all right thank you take a seat another
time
[Laughter]
interesting well this is their certified
this is certified
backup
but it's not like that easy
you know
and also like i'm assuming that
generally speaking women are
well
it's fast and if he's pulling hard that
kid is coming with him
it's not that easy you know what i mean
all right so the way that worked the way
that works
the child's arm i love that
it's like a release button it's like
yeah not it's not like that yeah i don't
know top of the morning top of the
morning let's get it there you go
now you could just carry a gun
that was what i was going to say abs
class was mace is not effective just
carry a clock yeah i mean compared to
what dude there was yeah there was like
three weeks where every day i feel like
i got an email it's like oh someone else
got uh abducted at school you know take
taken to an atm and
car stolen holy [ __ ] it was like three
weeks straight yeah whoa usually it was
a safe area i don't know so the defense
was a was a natural was a daily need
yeah i was scared of [ __ ] i was yeah so
were you prepared to get to get like
oh
attack
well i don't know i had my boosted board
so i kind of had a little bit of
advantage because i was the douche on
campus that was always like zooming by
everyone but leno would always say
that's dumb because not your target
exactly well yeah
yeah really sad it's like if you fall
you die you fall you die if i stay on
what was lena's strategy did she have
pepper spray usually i would walk with
selena yeah she had pepper spray that's
good yeah the first day and then she
went to that seminar and she's like oh
well that's a bad advice yeah carry the
pepper spray what did they tell you
because i feel like sometimes
people put too much confidence in it and
like someone's coming up and they're
like jingling and they're scared it's
like better just to run you got to have
it in your hand if you're walking at
night in a dangerous area
have it ready to go yeah
so that way if somebody you know comes
and greets you you spray them in the
[ __ ] face and ask questions later
they actually had a dude that looked
like this guy and he goes he had a
little
example of like a girl going like this
and he just like pushed her arm away
it might have been this one this guy's
exactly to be honest oh he was training
you guys that explains why he said don't
carry pepper
i think pepper spray is probably the
best option short of a knife or a gun
which probably you don't want to carry
nice knife's not great knife's not a
great option either because if you don't
know what you're doing with it you're
just as likely to well yeah this is
america just [ __ ] pat just bring a ak
bro just back like an ak-47 i'm worried
about it yeah
hold on let's get this [ __ ] you know
this is a huge uh story coming at you
guys
kim
kardashian the one and only
has made the stunning discovery
of
wikifeed
no
and this is kind of a
big moment in everybody's life every
celebrity's life when they discover
there's a website dedicated to raiding
their feet
here she is wait there is such thing as
a wiki feet oh my god look at my profile
[Laughter]
yeah yeah if you think that's crazy you
should go to pornhub and see what they
have about you there no
like
this is not this isn't even close to
some of the [ __ ] people have seen about
you have you visited blockchain
wait a minute all right like wait what
did your friend say i told you
[Laughter]
like they just like
wait there's a whole site called wiki
feet
that literally shows little piggies
they're judges wait there's a score yeah
yeah so what's my score what's my score
you have beautiful feet yes
the women's side is not very uh i feel
like all all women on that side get a
perfect five to be honest
the men there are very generous yeah
i mean i guess if you're there
you're interested in feet and you're
going to like what you see right now i
can fit into a size six and a half
but i like a seven but i think i'm
really no i'm a true seven but in
sneakers i wear a size eight or in me oh
so she's giving them intel well like if
you go to wiki feed
women
and sort by top
um the problem you know i i get i just
get a little upset honestly when i come
to this
page
because as you guys know i used to be
number one on the site for
for men
and it was just it just breaks my heart
what they did not only did they remove
me but they disabled ratings for all men
they said not only does ethan not to get
be number one but we're removing the
whole thing that's not true
for the women
margot robbie's number one
yeah and actually um i wonder if kim was
disappointed to see she i mean she's not
she's not in the top
echelon here let's see what margot
robbie's feet like
margot robbie is number one huh let's
take a look here
nice feet
i guess
right
sure
um so she's number one doesn't have like
gangrene or nothing's foot or anything
no fungus no fungus that's good victoria
justice yes she's not even oh emma emma
stone is making an appearance oh well
this girl is just this girl is just
pandering look at this [ __ ]
janelle what are you doing janelle
you're come on
see she's rigging the game you know what
i mean well wait until you see uh whoa
those feet are pretty wild they look
like cactuses her toes are like kind of
big toe with peace and love i'm just
calling it like i see it like well maybe
i guess
it's hard i don't have the rubric here i
don't know what the grading is because i
i this is this is not my fetish so it's
like oh really well so maybe i'm just
saying maybe the big toes that's a
that's a positive
yeah i mean
sure
maybe it is
i mean based on tozilla right there
being at the top i think so
i mean margo's weren't that no hers
looked normal nice those were normal
yeah but
it's making me wonder if this is just a
function of how attractive the people
think because this is all just like
you know
the most beautiful women in the world
type of thing but you know what i'm
thinking if i can't
participate on the men's side
then i think it's time
we infiltrate
the women's side
because they did a great injustice to us
and
i'm [ __ ] sick of it do we have to so
what are we gonna do we found that okay
so i'm thinking of infiltrating as ethel
klein
that's my new should we be giving this
intel out i feel like the wikipedia
moderators probably watch us like a hawk
now they forgot about this they think
the threat is neutralized okay we're
like uh we're like the you know you've
seen magneto when he's been locked away
in the plastic cell that's what we are
we're like the super villain that's been
locked away but little did they know
i'm clotting 10 pairs of socks layered
on your feet
right
the war oh do you hear that baby
it's the war horn
it's tooting yep it's blowing pokemane
is on page two of the women's side oh
for real that's the first shout out like
twitch youtuber i'm saying
shout out that's a huge honor yeah
let's see
well i'm gonna get number one
we'll see how long
i don't know these these ones have a lot
of vote it's going to take a lot of
effort to get me number one i'm worried
too because i feel like i feel like the
this is the big leagues yes exactly like
i think we flew under the radar for a
while on the men's side because nobody
cares about men yeah it's not as active
oh god they've got her stepping on pop
hamburger buns that's got to do it
that's got gotta do it for the dudes
watching the stomping on [ __ ]
for sure are you gonna like manicure
your feet like you're gonna paint your
toes hell no are we gonna use like the
face app thing to to gender swap you
we're putting ethan in drag oh you're
just going to dress yeah so do i have
should just maybe we should do this on
friday live that'd be so fun yeah yeah
so we so we're going to plot so get it
ready on friday we're going to make our
we're going to make our stand once and
for all ethel's foot calendar maybe i
should do some stomping
yeah
because i think the stomping is
yeah really we're very powerful
yeah maybe some face swap do a gender
spa
because she looks real
ethel
yeah she's a real person
dude i don't know this is gonna be tough
because i just looked at margot robbie's
look at this photo bro rating
yeah she's she has
over 5 000 five stars
bro look at this photo
[Music]
we need to get your feet to swell up you
want that number one spot we're good why
her feet look normal you gotta get rid
of the toe hair yo this photo is crazy
she wants that number one spot so bad
she's going shh don't tell people that i
told my fans to give me five
minutes she have a toe ring
yeah she does you think i need some toe
jewelry that's game over right there
dude you think i need toe jewelry game
over
yeah so ethel klein is gonna be coming
out on friday we're gonna have to do
like a photo shoot and gender swap
stomping
maybe we could pick up some toe jewelry
for friday
get those feet in here well how how are
they gonna say like if i'm gender
swapped how are they gonna say
i'm not the real deal
and there's gonna be like legit tons of
dudes i think what [ __ ] we gender swap
jerking off to my feet
one can only help
i just want to point out margot robbie
has a tattoo on her feet
oh she does yeah
i keep it pure
oh natural yeah so are you going to
shave your toe hair like what are you
well yes sure i can maybe we should wax
my toes as part of the segment waxing my
toes interesting interesting i have some
pretty gnarly toys it's going to be
painful so here's what we're going to do
on friday
jewelry waxing we'll do that on the show
we're going to infiltrate do you want me
to do your makeup
no just because it'll be a gender swap
yeah we'll rely on the app oh yeah
remember the japanese motorcyclist who
like
just face apt into like this beautiful
young girl yeah
i'm real i'm ethel
what the [ __ ] is love doing
um i thought we were going into war oh
wait are you wearing face pants he's
geared up i think it's a filter oh
that's a filter i was looking at it from
far away no okay sorry that looks really
good you look good with with that much
stubble dude
yeah i wish i could uh actually grow
fish there
that is insanely good filter
so that's exciting yeah exciting stuff
guys
so i'm trying to time this out because
the
squid games is gonna be about 30 minutes
i don't want to do a short episode
because we love you guys
we'll do a full two-hour app how long
we've been going down uh about an hour
if we do like one more segment and then
we can go to do the games all right what
do you guys like we've got
the twitch data leak i want to do with
hassan tomorrow
um this girl selling pictures of her
newborn demi lovato abducted by aliens
is pretty awesome
god
she's she is rocketing up my my list of
most hated famous people real fast i
mean she's just a little kooky isn't she
i mean the yogurt situation was the one
thing but
and then i had a hard time the rest of
the weekend no yeah i get it
well so demi lovato of yogurt fame
oh so
demi uses they them so
i will uh respect that of course
i'll try to i might slip up just because
i'm a boomer and i'm not used to saying
it like that
uh demi lovato
from yogurt fame
yep
went to she was in the news recently for
going through he already [ __ ] it up oh
my god
demi lovato went to the yogurt store
and demi
got
she they didn't have the yogurt they
wanted
i'm not trying to be funny no i know
you're not it's challenging
i know it is yeah thank you
thank you i'm trying my best we respect
that you're trying and uh demi
uh they did not have the yogurt they
wanted
and
they tried to cancel the yogurt store go
ahead zach and then i had a hard time
the rest of the weekend it ruined
it ruined demi's entire weekend
okay
tragic well truly tragic
well
uh demi has gone on the
kelly clarkson show clarkson clark
clarkson you got it
and
they said that they've been abducted by
aliens so this is demi's new thinker
i had a night where i was dreaming and
i say dreaming very loosely because oh
they were dreaming yeah that sounds like
an organization story's over
i don't really know what happened but i
all of a sudden was in my room and and i
know i said i so
i i stopped you you were dreaming
but this is going to sound so out there
but just bear with me so i woke up in my
room and there was like three beings
and then and they
they were oh do you want to see your
planet and i was like
oh sorry
sorry you were like hell i was like hell
yeah let's go
so
no
i like whooshed out of my room and was
like hovering over the planet and then
all of a sudden they're like you want to
see our planet and i was like
hell yeah yeah
then i wish to this like pink and purple
planet that i've never seen but
and then and so that with the
hypnotherapy i was like trying to figure
out what exactly that was was it like
i don't want to use the word abduction
because that implies that it wasn't with
consent i was totally for it
you know what you said hell yes
so i can't call it like an abduction i
called it an astral projection for a
long time because i went somewhere else
yeah but then i realized maybe this was
just an encounter that i had yeah and i
talk about that we actually have photos
of the of the planet they visited
um planet yogurt in fact i believe was
the planet so
they finally got that yogurt and that's
that's why demi's so happy
that's awesome i visited the planet and
it was just a big yogurt ball i'm so
happy with fruit and
and
raisins
and i was so happy
and i said hell yeah
and one of the other planets had even
like a stick of cookie coming out of it
[Applause]
and it smelled of strawberry
and i was like
hell yeah
and it was also gluten-free which is my
preference for planets
[Music]
it was non-dairy planet
[Music]
oh yeah
yeah this is wild man i don't know
like i guess the kelly clarkson show
isn't really the hardest hitting but i
do find it odd how she's like
so down with this story
uh even though she's obviously being
confronted with
what can only be described as a
uh
psychotic delusion or straight up dream
yeah hell yeah
funny thing you're talking about this
like because is stuff like that real or
is that you're just like so
vulnerable and your walls are down and
you're so like that i sound like a
stoner
wait so but wait demi was
demi is a drug user right or she was i'm
not sure if they i'm not familiar with
the i watched their documentary last
year um i'm pretty sure
the way that it ended was that
the best thing for them was to use drugs
in moderation or something oh my
goodness um yeah they have a mushroom
room in our house
so
they were dreaming
they were on mushrooms
i didn't realize that because i almost
made the joke
when they were describing their
experience that yeah i've done salvia
too salvia right holy sounds like a
salvia trip
like 100
well they also uh
recently had an overdose correct yeah a
few years ago
i think woman was it on heroin
oh well that well that'll send you to
planet yogurt oh yeah well that's what
this documentary was about like the
entire thing was about them getting
clean and like not wanting to od again
and then at the end it was just kind of
like and now i'm using them a little bit
i smoke marijuana but i don't know maybe
they don't beat my
children yeah well
well actually we we there it is yeah we
transcended time and space and actually
visited the same planet uh they did
i
and it turns out that all i had to do
was eat a bunch of mushrooms
take a tiny bit of heroin just to you
know set the tone and just a fat bomb
what's good what's good about heroin is
that it takes the edge off the mushrooms
and then you can really transcend no
that is true yeah
so they have a a new show
uh called unidentified with demi lovato
and it is all about aliens and stuff wow
it's on peacock so if
wow wow wow so if you want more of this
hard-hitting content that's where to
find well i kind of do to be honest with
you i will be watching yeah i mean give
us a report olivia i'm very curious
i had a lot of
exposure to
people that um
claimed to be abducted by aliens in
my old life when i was working all of
those uh bizarre spiritual commitment
like the brazzo type set
um
they
they've all been abducted by aliens
somehow oh for real oh
almost universally wow um or beings of
light
uh as they described it in that kelly
clarkson clip um
and
yeah it's uh
it's it
through the process of doing all those
it kind of became a pet peeve of mine
because all of them
inevitably are selling something it's
it's like like like so many things in
life it's all you're saying the gurus
were all abducted are the people that
visited the gurus well a combination of
both but but yeah i'm mostly referring
to the gurus yes they've okay they've
been abducted what were they selling
like alien uh abduction cream uh some
the one i won't
i don't remember the name of this guy
but he was one that
absolutely infuriated me because he was
so transparently um predatory of these
people and he he was literally selling
alien encounter um
like trips he would take people out oh
wow for like five days yeah supposedly
like pretty much guarantee that you will
have an encounter wow he's got the hook
the alien hookup yeah i don't know if he
was dosing these people or what but uh
that's really interesting uh yeah so um
i would call that a fraud yeah
hey come on you're not saying that
that's what uh demi is doing here
however the fact that they are suddenly
talking about all of this and then they
happen to have a show about yeah
promoting yeah so do you not believe in
aliens
i believe that aliens exist 100 i do not
believe most people who tell you that
they are interacting with aliens on a on
a regular basis because that's the thing
a lot of them they have these elaborate
fictions where there's a whole galactic
federation that they're in contact with
and there's warring factions
you're the point man right and they're
and this and this person is the people
they have chosen me of the human race to
to represent everybody yeah i mean and
if you pay me a hundred dollars i'm
gonna take you into the desert right
they're always there
it costs a lot of money to go see
they have you know a uh 10 set dvd set
that will tell you all the secrets of
the iteration for
you know nine easy payments of well hold
on olivia do you believe in alien
abduction because
um
i mean i believe that like life exists
somewhere else i don't know if
are they here abducting demi lovato and
taking them to planet yogurt
would love for that to be true yeah i
want it to be true as well that's
i'm not i'm i'm not a stoner i just i
just mean like it was interesting
watching this show because i was like
wait so maybe it's like it really
doesn't allow you because it's one
character and she hated the show you can
tell she hated it
she's like it was really interesting
watching this show their walls down and
like and and you're like well maybe
that's what they really are feeling and
they just weren't able to feel that and
it's really real so i don't know i'm not
against all of it being real yeah i'm
just terrified of it being wrong jimmy's
nodding her head like you didn't want
common misunderstanding that that these
beings are bad because this is movies
that we've seen oh yeah like short
opinions day yeah like it's like we do
with sharks yeah you make them horrible
they're just yeah yes but i think
they've been here longer i think that
they've been here longer and i think
that oh you're talking about sharks
[Laughter]
what a conversation i just made an
amazing discovery i was trying to
remember the name of the guy that was
talking about the one in particular that
sold the alien encounters and everything
and just was is he in jail
[Music]
here he is on a podcast with demi like
three months ago wait this is
not this is the guy
wait i've seen this guy he was on rogan
once
that's probably where you saw him
this guy oh my god he's a mega douche
let me tell you wait wait wait wait wait
this is the guy this is the problem i
have with rogan this guy is
based on what you've heard and what i've
seen him say i pretty other he is a
total [ __ ] quack fraud completely
total
fraud yep
okay let's listen
i mean i i've embedded this i just it
just popped up when i was searching
around for his name and it was 4d baby
4d i guess this is a podcast that they
have also on the topic formally have
been military military attacks military
he claims all of his information comes
from the cia by the way which he has
deep ties to
according to him
this is all kinds of frankly really
stupid dangerous things so i tell people
that this dude he's like beetlejuice
coming together
[Laughter]
is he a doctor what the [ __ ] you doctor
of look up his credentials um i did a
long time ago so i did i did an event
with this doctor stealing yo cash
they won the nobel prize yeah the movie
won the nobel prize so it's all good uh
let's see
says he's a ufo ologist yeah i don't
really
shoot doctorate for that one uh no i i'm
sure
yeah he's an md who's md actually uh uh
demi in space she joined the enterprise
here she is on the on the not the
enterprise what was the original one
anyway she was spock there so that was
the answer they are
they're always the enterprise it is yeah
oh
i thought though okay so
greer is one of 40 episodes that spotify
removed of joe rogan's podcast really oh
oh
[Laughter]
wait you said he's an md dan yep major
douche oh got him
got him ufo ology what a [ __ ]
douchebag and like i said i mean this
was the guy that he
did like a
weekend seminar that costs i don't
remember the cost but more than it was
worth let's just say that and then all
of it was basically just a big ad to get
people to pay him to take them out on a
camping trip in the desert so that they
could see aliens
here's a clip from the show unidentified
with demi lovato where she
um
apparently communicates with aliens by
singing
their 2011 hit skyscraper
after
[Laughter]
after singing a machine that is supposed
to detect exterior extraterrestrial
activity makes a noise so
this is how she uh communicates so here
you have it when i feel
sure singing something emotional
[Music]
do you have to
make me feel like
there's nothing left
[Music]
i love
[Music]
like a sky the galactic federation was
about to arrive like next week
and they'd [ __ ] turn around i tailed
it out she was just you know what what
or sorry they you know what they were
doing it was the show me your moves from
rick and morty and she failed they
bounced
they destroyed our planet
here's another guest
oh my god i can't even get br brett
rockman
wait might help if you know their name
wait bretman rock that's not his name is
it yeah oh that was bread rockman
here's another one that blew me away
drew barrymore that doesn't surprise me
at all
yeah that one is a little more
predictable i suppose i mean look demi
lovato
is famous so it doesn't surprise you oh
yeah i mean
17 and a half million subs on this
channel 150 i would bring yogurt for her
if i got invited
it better be the right be the one that
it better be the right kind oh yeah i
would make sure you want to stick around
i would make sure hey
well you know
i i listen i want aliens to be real too
here's this oh by the way here's just
these people here's the machine making
the noise acknowledging that the aliens
uh oh it's the same link i didn't hear
the machine making a sound did you yeah
i was writing something emotional
scraper
oh i heard it
yeah she got a standing oh from the
aliens
day i'm sorry guys i'm i'm sorry
i'm really trying my best here
it's hard i don't know why i've never
it's just it's tough i'm trying my best
peace and love
um
by the way i just want to say this since
we're on the topic
trish trisha fans always get mad at me
for calling her she she has in her bio
that she goes by she her and she always
says that her close family and friends
call her her so
i just don't know why people get mad at
me for saying she like that's how she
goes
that's it that's all i wanted to say
thank you but i'm trying with demi
trying to respect her pronouns
they're pronouns they're pronouns i am
trying i really am
i'm trying to respect their pronouns
oh we got one more
we got one more
there we go
um i want to believe
[Laughter]
so this is a yogurt uh
a yogurt aircraft from space perfect
flavor
exactly what they ordered
and it's coming down
to take over and that is a dream we can
all share
thank you
i want to believe
um we also have
lindsay lohan furry nft
i think we're probably good i was about
to say i think we need to move on to the
game right so then without further ado
it is time for
squid games
uh
isn't it squid game
oh
okay there's no s
squid game but there's games it's game
okay it's squid game you're okay dan
thanks thanks joe
joe's got a lot of
positive reinforcement for me yeah i
really appreciate it all the presidents
love you dan
yes so um squid game okay
can we move on now yeah yeah all right
squid game no ass people
my mom does that same thing she adds a s
to everything
well this one
is understandable there's games yeah
squid game
alrighty
we'll see on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the h3 squid game five four
three two one go
the [ __ ]
wow
wow
dan thought he would be dead a b what
happened to you abby just like like
laser focused on even like running and
i'm like oh you can do that i can do
that dude i smoked y'all
win it for me
i believe in you that i believe in him
you can do it zack
execute him
[Laughter]
313
eliminated
who's made a paper airplane before thank
you
zach shook his head
never could i helped zach try him no no
what though [ __ ] he's back this is the
squid game he's the old man i feel bad
zach needs to die so i can live
because his looks is not that bad did he
peek over my shoulder a little maybe
guard do maybe some cheating going on
over there you're out of time kill dan
shoot him guard guard shoot him zap
right in the eye all right go ahead ian
here give me give me a little room give
me a little room
what is that
whoa
you've got reverse special over here
kill me now yo ian you're going
backwards i've never seen that
wow these are
okay oh
spooky you you might have a chance out
here
zax goes the farthest i swear
okay oh pretty good olivia
come on baby
never made a paper airplane before
somebody
kill zach
[Applause]
[Music]
i got this
do you have your passports did you get
your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
america
did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
[Music]
it's going for a while
i'm scared
wow the biggest guy olivia what the
snack
well
that means you have to take salt shot to
the eye my dude to the eye
point blank should be the back of the
head execution style so right in the ear
hole in the ear hole up the nose or in
the eye you choose zach goodbye gentle
zack
oh come on what kind of punishment is
that
yeah that's his [ __ ] execute this
[ __ ]
count it down please point it down
oh
holy [ __ ]
oh here you don't need to
that was a good one man
[ __ ]
damn what the [ __ ] you got the murder
balls dude
i didn't think that [ __ ] this
[ __ ] he got egged he got [ __ ]
egg dude you're being dramatic dude i
[ __ ] i can't i gotta wear it that bad
[ __ ] size of the united states here
we go all right why don't you do it why
don't you do it huh okay so you better
shoot him in the shoot him in the
[ __ ] that's where i want him
yeah i hit him and then i did hit him in
the nuts with the egg get ready to float
zach thinks he's being a baby and they
both agreed for me to shoot a b
theoretically already dead but this is
just for the fun i guess it hurts all
right i'm gonna give him a good one for
you zacky
thank you okay ready
see it didn't explode
one more
tough guy
that one popped it was right in his
[ __ ] spine you're holding it in right
now one more
time
oh yeah he got a good one oh dude
you're l4 right there
oh my god dan is already making me
nervous i can't see what i'm doing say
can you flip to the other side uh guard
sure
she said sure
top of the morning top of the morning
let's get this [ __ ] let's get this [ __ ]
steady
steady
you're [ __ ] around you got pretty
close to that hell no dude not even
yeah that one yeah
our first non-center going off the rails
oh my god
that looks pretty
i mean i mean this guard looks pretty
small can i just beat her up take her
gun kill everybody oh [ __ ]
i think you're committed to that
blockage i'm not committed to [ __ ] dude
but halfway through the [ __ ] up you
can't [ __ ] i could do whatever i want
it's squid games you haven't even seen
the show so what the rules are whatever
i make it dude
and she's getting her gun ready
she's getting her gun ready this is the
end guys
what happened that one's pretty pretty
essential this is a load-bearing block
it might it may well be oh it's going
down
it's going down get the slow-mo ready
mom get the camera
[Laughter]
no
i got this no problem
this is where i come slide one out
no stop no
no he can't do that
he can't
keep getting away with it
i'm so mad at you
i told you it's no problem
this is actually yeah this is we're
still in the day oh god
we're still in the danger zone
it's so ready to go
what how the [ __ ] that doesn't make
sense it's probably gonna fall but
i mean where else is there to go you
can't take that one dan oh
no oh
liner up boys
oh hold on i'm dead you'll fall down
then oh my god bounce right off you now
we gotta dump the the django pieces on
her or something player 602
eliminated
[Music]
i know what to do with this
i
think i understand so you're just
supposed to poke this out right get the
star watch the show
get the star
out of there okay all right here i uh i
was given a little advice you were by
one of the other contestants yeah what'd
they show you they told me there was a
key moment in the show you can start
licking this thing a lighter what the
[ __ ] i left that thing in there and it
can help you bro how is there not a
timer we're just gonna let dan like like
spark it up
oh it's a race oh
okay wow
interesting i gotta say
the
moment that i
touched it after using the lighter oh
did you already break it no you're good
you want to get the shape out oh is that
okay oh you just don't want to break the
middle yeah oh okay yeah maybe one dude
oh they said don't break the cookie you
can't break the shape
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] b
now we're [ __ ] we're literally
cooking with gas now
oh you're done
i think i lost
that's pretty much perfect
why are you dying what are you doing
over here like cooking up an airplane
what are you doing
hey you're dead though i still lost but
not bad sure all right let's go kill you
all right
all right here we go
rest in peace dan
that was a good one did that hurt
that was a that was like a good one
that was like a zack shot right there
boy
like drag them away player 147
eliminated
i am the squid game winner usually i
would be paying you there needs to be a
prize as you guys know so
obviously obviously i can't pay myself
so what i'm gonna i've decided is that
nobody gets the salary this month
[Music]
i get to save the
the payroll
come on dan be happy for me olivia you
happy i won
yeah
guards
no payroll this month everybody
shannon
no paycheck cam no paycheck for you
either ian
you owe me money this month
you're in the negative this time boy
may the best man win